there are images of police using
violence against peaceful protesters
there are images of police creating
confrontations even attacking but
defenseless elderly people we played a
video of police knocking over an elderly
man with a cane shooting at the media
these images have gone viral
over the weekend now I want to be really
clear I already did a story about how
what's going on in America right now is
not just about one thing it's not just
about race it's not only about police
it's not exclusively about capitalism or
Trump this is a massive multifaceted
ordeal but that doesn't mean that we
shouldn't look at individual elements
and one of these elements is the idea of
police as oppressors versus police's
victims as some have started framing
police to be we are seeing wholesale
pepper spraying of peaceful protesters
we've seen members of the media shot
with rubber bullets we saw kids hit with
pepper spray we've seen police ramming
police vehicles into crowds a Dallas
woman was hit in the face with a rubber
bullet while walking home with her
groceries police wildly hitting people
with batons in some cases people walking
away from protests none of this excuses
any violent actions by protesters and
there have been horrible actions
including attacking business owners
beating one business owner to within an
inch of his life for trying to defend
his business beating a female business
owner brutally out in front of her store
we have seen it all but I want to focus
in a little bit here on the police
component and talk about it with you
there are people and I'm friends with
some of them on Facebook I'm seeing it
on Twitter there are people who have
immediately taken to painting police's
victims arguments like a bad cop may
have killed George Floyd in Minnesota
but now innocent police all over the
place are being attacked for no reason
and often these arguments end up in
debates about numbers like well most
police are good ways it 97 percent or 99
percent well is it 99 or ninety nine
point three percent and I said earlier
in the show imagine we
out with some precision what portion of
police are the problem is we might call
it and what portion of police are not
imagine ninety nine point two percent of
police are good okay
well I imagine that most of my audience
even if you're okay with property crime
in protests where insurance companies
are the ones taking a hit in
corporations I imagine most of my
audience is not okay with unprovoked
attacks against random police officers
who aren't doing anything wrong if you
do believe that for what happened to
George Floyd in Minnesota it's okay to
just physically attack an officer in
Miami we're just not on the same page I
think that's the minority of my audience
does our analysis depend though on
whether it's ninety nine point two or
ninety nine point three percent of
police that are good guys in it for the
right reasons because what really this
is about is context and power dynamics
in total once you concede that most cops
are good and doing their job as best
they can often in difficult situations
sometimes dangerous situations you also
have some cops that go into law
enforcement specifically because they
would love an opportunity to beat the
crap out of someone just like some
portion of people go into the military
because they like the idea of shooting
someone and killing them in some kind of
a theater of war at some point that is
some percentage okay so so then what
right whether it's 0.8 or 0.7 or 0.08
percent of police that are going in
because they want to do violence and
misbehave and have all the worst
intentions what next and that's where
the more difficult conversations start
questions like are the good cops who are
just doing their job part of the problem
in that if you're not part of the
solution are you implicitly supporting
the status quo of that small percentage
of police that do horrible things and
get away with it
to what degree should every quote good
cop quit in protest to show solidarity
with the protests leaving our country to
be policed only by the bad cops
what can
as a sign of being complicit is silence
a sign of being complicit
what power and responsibility do
individual police officers have to fix
the problem versus police chiefs versus
federal law enforcement agencies versus
versus police unions that represent
officers around the country should the
good cops be treated respectfully or
suspiciously absent any reason to
believe they are one of the bad cops
how should they be treated by protesters
the average person etc when you start
asking these questions you realize that
most of the changes that need to be made
are systemic changes it needs to be much
more likely that if you do the wrong
thing as a police officer you will be
caught and punished it's not likely
right now in a lot of our society just
from this weekend
we have dozens if not hundreds of
officers on video doing horrible things
are we confident they're going to be
identified and investigated and charged
and punished when it's appropriate not
really because if it were more likely
that they were held accountable they
would probably change their behavior
that is a systemic issue a good system
will take care of that sliver of police
that are doing SiC horrible things so
let's answer the questions one by one
first of all being a police officer is
not like being an accountant okay
accountants don't represent communities
in the way that police officers do
accountants don't wield their power with
firearms and accountants don't have a
power dynamic relative to their clients
the way police officers have a power
dynamic a relative to the people that
they are dealing with so on the one hand
the good police officers must say much
more loudly these things are not okay
and we're committed to fixing it and
changing it and good for them many
police officers have done exactly that
at the same time the anger by protesters
towards a system of policing that is
fundamentally broken in many parts of
our country is justified anger and this
is why it's so powerful when police
officers get it and say I'm with you
like the
sheriff in Michigan who marched with
protesters and the video going viral and
it's important for protesters to know
that their anger with the system is
justified and yet it's not okay to go
attack random individual cops who have
not done anything wrong which is why it
was great to see protesters protecting a
police officer Saturday night who had
done nothing wrong and was separated
from his squad this is why it was great
to see video from I believe it was
Brooklyn last night with organizers
saying do not interact with the police
we are not here for that we are here to
get our message out do not incite
violence if you see anyone inciting
violence call them out and you know in
the midst of this there's this really
ugly thing that's going on where there
are people sort of making the focus that
the protesters are from out of town and
at one point there was some wrong report
that more than half of protesters in
some place were from out of town
another report it said it seemed like
one out of seven were from out of town
now sometimes that could mean the next
town over it's not really a big deal but
the point is this out of town narrative
is being used to imply that you merely
have people from other communities who
are not coming in to protest because
they actually are concerned about police
brutality and relations or whatever but
that they are coming in to provoke or to
loot or to steal you could be concerned
about what went on and drive from
another state and it also appears to be
completely untrue so we've got to be
really understanding of how some of
these narratives are being used to
distort and discredit real justifiable
anger we also have to recognize the
growing number of protests that are
saying we are not here to do violence at
all and we are not here to do violence
to the police but we have to realize
that the anger is justified given the
systemic dynamics that exist that's sort
of my sense of it right now I'm glad to
hear from you about it as well